last question today's from Shannon
Shannon says David is Jesse Lee Peterson
playing a character on his show or is he
for real
very good question if you don't know who
Jesse Lee Peterson is he is a black
conservative who believes that whites
are oppressed and blacks are thugs and I
don't know what else what other words he
attributes to them he has a couple of
different shows he has one radio show
and then he has a youtube show called
the fallen state on which I appeared
when I was in Los Angeles a few months
ago a very popular video on our YouTube
channel I think it's something like
Jesse Lee Peterson desperate to control
David or something like that and he
plays this wacky exaggerated trumpet on
the show and unless he's also pretending
in front of me when the cameras are off
that's really him it's not a character
when the cameras went off he was talking
to me about David I know you're gonna
vote for Trump the great white hope in
2020 which is exactly the type of stuff
he says on his show he was talking about
politics in a way that was completely in
line with what he says on the show so
I've said before like when I met Alex
Jones he did seem to be playing a
character when I met him privately but
then his ex-wife on the show said he's
not playing a character and then Joe
Rogan recently said it does sort of seem
like this is the real Joe of Alex Jones
that something has happened and this is
now the real Alex Jones my sense with
Jessie Lee Peterson is that he is not
playing a character he even made a
statements off off screen which he
wouldn't characterize him this way but
he said racist things about black people
just in front of me and like his
production staff which i think is mostly
white he made comments about as he calls
them Mexicans in private when as far as
I know you wouldn't think he would be
performing unless he's just performing a
firt for me so Jesse Lee Peterson to the
best of my knowledge is not playing a
character on his show that's really him
he behaves the exact same way at least
off-camera when I was at his
Judeo at his christian men's counseling
center or whatever it is in los angeles
and interestingly at least a couple of
Jesse Lee Peterson's staffers seem to be
pretty big David Pakman show fans who
wanted to take pictures with me and this
whole thing so I don't even know what
their politics are or if they just found
me to be generally nice because I was
nice to them as I'm nice to anyone that
doesn't attack me as soon as I meet them
and they were polite so that's that I
think he probably is not playing a
character and we are currently working
my manager is currently working on an
event involving Jesse Lee Peterson I
don't want to say more about it but it's
potentially very very exciting and I
hope to be able to announce it to you
could be a couple of months but I'll get
back to you about that we've got a great
bonus show coming up for you today two
ways to access the bonus show become a
member at WWE pakman.com or become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show either way you'll get access to the
Members Only bonus show which is daily
for our paid subscribers and either way
you'll be supporting progressive
independent media to self fund and not
depend on big advertisers or media
conglomerates so it's good all around
and I look forward to speaking to you on
the bonus show one of today's sponsors
is minds.com
minds is an open source social network
platform it's kind of like YouTube
Facebook and Twitter all in one package
except that the goal of minds is to help
create a free and open Internet where
privacy and free speech are the top
priority and to make sure that content
creators are fairly compensated for
their efforts mine's doesn't track you
like a lot of other social networks do
and users on minds can earn minds tokens
for interacting with the site such as
when you like dislike or share content
or when you create content yourself by
uploading a photo or video or writing a
blog post then your minds tokens can be
used to boost your content on the site
so that more
we'll see it mines even offers a feature
kind of like patreon where your fans can
unlock your premium content by sending
you minds tokens everything is encrypted
for example minds can't read your
private messages on the platform and
like I mentioned everything is open
source meaning that in the interest of
transparency you can actually see the
code that fuels the site which is
definitely not something that lots of
other social and content sharing
platforms can say mine's sees a lot of
issues with today's most popular social
media platforms especially when it comes
to free speech privacy transparency and
compensating content creators and those
are the problems that they're trying to
solve I encourage you to go check it out
at minds.com there's also a mobile app
and you can actually follow the david
pakman show on minds at minds.com slash
david pakman show I've also put a link
right underneath this video